hi everyone Thank You stranger for
having me my name is Amy Bravo and on
the internet I am Sailor hg I recently
left my job as a web developer at Airbnb
to write seems about computer science
because I don't feel like we currently
emphasize enough the creative aspects of
computer science and also how much
computer science can tie into other
subjects in computer science education
and with that as a segue today I'm going
to talk to you about knitting now before
you get it to leave because you think
you might be at the wrong conference I
want to assure you that this talk is
about problem solving hardware hacking
and even has some programming and some
code in it you're just going to have to
wait to see how so I'll stories start
with an inspiration and here is a
somewhat unexpected start of this story
a few years ago a video game website
called kotaku published an article about
super nintendo peripherals that never
quite made the cut you've probably heard
of some of the outlandish add-ons that
did get produced there was a baseball
bat for playing baseball video games a
golf club for playing golf video games a
super scope wireless gun for shooting
games but you might not have known that
Nintendo was seriously contemplating
making a knitting peripheral for the
SNES and this is the proposed
advertisement for this peripheral
complete with horrible puns I'm not sure
if you can read it but in the bottom
right corner it literally says why
needle the competition so the interface
would be like mario paint but instead of
just pictures as outputs you could get
your design on scarf or mittens or socks
so most of the comments left on the
kotaku article were along the lines of
law what we see why this one never made
it to production or what were they even
thinking but I had a really different
reaction to reading this article and it
was that I was so heartbroken because I
had I had never wanted so badly for
something to exist I felt like if I had
one I would just use it all the time and
make myself all kinds of socks and
sweaters and mittens and so
it was time for me to do research did
Nintendo have any prototypes that I
could get my hands on where was there
any other company that made knitting
machines for home use after a lot of
research it turned out that a bunch of
companies made knitting machines in the
1980s but they never really took off so
they were discontinued and that's when
my dream was born to get my hands on one
of these old machines and to make the
Super Nintendo add-on that never was and
as fate would have it I found one of
these super old knitting machines on
craigslist at an address about an hour
and a half away and it was old and parts
were missing but it was a start it was a
start to my dream and to summarize this
dream again in cartoon form it was to
have into the machine that could take
images from my computer and turn them
into sweaters basically to create a
network yarn printer so now that I had
gotten hold of one of these things the
first thing I needed to do was learn how
to use the damn thing because just
figuring out how to use the built-in
basic functionality of the knitting
machine let alone hacking it was
daunting because this is what a knitting
machine looks like it has 200 knitting
needles that move in and out you can
thread up to two different colors of
yarn to produce patterns and it came
with a manual that was like this thick
that was full of knitting terms that I
had never heard of and if this is what
using a knitting knitting machine looks
like this is what using editing machine
feels like there are so many buttons and
moving parts it totally felt like
operating the control station of a
starship like my teammates and I would
later joke about how we felt like we
were basically playing space team and I
one was worried that if i press the
wrong thing this would happen or at
least that I would break some of the
needles and have no idea how to fix them
luckily I had a team of people to help
me face the knitting machine that was
both fearless and inventive this is a
team of Araby
the engineers that help me hack a
knitting machine for one of airbnb s
internal hackathons Airbnb hosts
internal hackathons twice a year for the
entire product team both designers and
engineers and a lot of people now ask me
how did you ever convince anyone to work
on this with you and believe me I'm
surprised too I had no idea if anyone
else would be interested in working on
this project with me so I was really
surprised that there was so much
interest when I pitched the idea so many
people came up to me saying that they
wanted to work on it with me that were
as excited as I was or even more excited
and there were so many different kinds
of engineers that signed up to help me
an iOS engineer and SRV a performance
engineer a data infrastructure engineer
a front-end engineer that's all to say
that we were a bunch of Engineers who
knew nothing about knitting or knitting
machines so this was just kind of a
crazy adventure that we were all in on
together and I think that that made it
one of the best teams that I've ever
worked with we had zero ego attached to
machine knitting and so this was just an
adventure that we were all in together
going back to Jabba the Hutt the reason
we had to be fearless was that the
knitting machine was really daunting and
this was the problem we had no idea how
to solve an inventive because this was
technology from the 80s and the Machine
was missing some of its parts and we had
to MacGyver some replacement parts but
the good thing about being engineer is
that you can apply your problem-solving
skills to anything even knitting so this
is an example of a problem that we
needed to be resourceful and inventive
to solve it felt like we were
encountering problems at every step of
the way even before turning the machine
on just preparing the yarn for the
machine was difficult when you buy yarn
from a store you'll usually find that
it's in a ball or in a little twist and
that's because it's optimized for ham
knitters but in order to feed yarn into
a machine it has to be wound into a
spool kind of like for a sewing machine
and if it's in a spool then it can be
fed into the machine at an
even rate so our machine came with a
contraption to turn balls of yarn into
spools but it had a bunch of parts
missing so we had to MacGyver a solution
from paper cups and this is one of my
teammates Dave using our macgyvered
coffee cups fuller
so after we set up the machine and
successfully learn to knit solid rows of
a single color the next step was to use
the machine to knit some of its built-in
patterns it comes with a book listing
samples of all the patterns and the
numbers that you could input to use them
and it forms the patterns by alternating
two different colors of yarn and even
though this was something that was built
into the machine already it still felt
like we were leveling up in machine
knitting because it required reading
like an extra 20 pages in the manual and
there was like twice as much yarn that
could get tangled and just to show you
how non-trivial this stuff was on the
left is our first attempt to knit a
built-in pattern which was supposed to
look like polka dots and after a couple
hours you can see the polka dots we
finally knit on the right another
example of using engineering problem
solving for knitting was that the
machine we noticed that it would get ten
to stuck would tend to get stuck more
often with two different colors of yarn
which makes sense there's like more to
get tangled so we experimented with like
different thicknesses of yarn and
different materials of yarn and wrote
down which ones tended to work best and
like adjusted our hypotheses from our
observations so we ended up finding out
that using animal-based yarns were less
likely to get stuck and we think that it
was because of the natural oils that
were already in the fibers so after we
figured out how to knit the machines
built in patterns we still hadn't
achieved our dream yet as far as we
could tell the intended user of a
knitting machine from the 1980s was a
grandma because the built-in patterns
were all things like bows and teddy
bears and I don't know about you but I
would rather have a sweater with a
grumpy cat on it than a sweater with a
teddy bear so we still wanted to figure
out how to send the Machine our own
images which was step three of our goal
and this school we would split into
several parts
so because it's from the 1980s the
knitting machine takes additional
patterns via floppy drive back then you
could buy additional pattern packs on
floppy disks so we could send our own
images to the knitting machine by
emulating a floppy drive on our computer
and then we needed to build a custom
table because the knitting machine had a
serial input and output but it had a
really strange pin out so we had to read
we had to research what the pin out for
the machine was and build our own custom
cable that was USB to serial port the
next step was to convert our input
images to low res one bit bitmaps which
was the file format for the knitting
machine there are a couple different
ways to do this but we wanted to use the
conversion algorithm that supported
dithering and luckily we also find a
library for this piece so with all these
pieces together we can have our knitting
machine read from our computer as if it
were a floppy drive so here's one of our
first custom patterns note the dithering
on the Shiva
if it's hard to read it says Wow oh my
god such fair isle and here's grumpy cat
so we were having entirely too much fun
with this but we kind of felt like we
were hogging all of the Sun we didn't
want sending pictures to the knitting
machine to be limited to just us who had
been learning how to use a machine for a
couple days we wanted anyone in our
office to be able to print memes from
yarn we wanted to share the fun so the
next step was to make machine knitting
available on the web it would be a super
simple interface you would choose a
photo to upload you would send the image
to the machine and then the web browser
would give you instructions for the
buttons to press on the machine to start
knitting your pattern and here's a video
the whole thing in action
you
and I have a bunch of knitting samples
with me here if you want to come look at
them later and here's a close-up of the
input image and the knitted output in
case that was too small in a video and
now we can look at the code that made
this possible it's in Ruby and Sinatra
and it's super simple so we load in some
libraries including a rapper library for
a rapper for a library that converts the
images to two bit to one bit bitmaps
that we call in knitting patterns and
then a wrapper for the floppy disk drive
library that we call a pattern just
drive and then when the user presses the
upload button we save the users photo to
a file use the image processing library
to convert the image to a 1-bit bitmap
and then start emulating the floppy disk
drive and then meanwhile in the web
browser we display instructions for the
user for which buttons they should be
pressing on the knitting machine and
this is the view for the upload form so
the things that we learned on this lid
venture first of all we gain mad respect
for grandmothers and anyone who knits
because that should is hard
I recall so many times at my teammates
said things like I thought that my job
was hard but optimizing database queries
has nothing on this another learning was
that teams work really well when
everyone operates with zero ego at stake
also it's really enjoyable to apply
programming to any of your hobbies no
matter how unrelated they might seem
especially hobby is related to creating
and also when you start exploring the
union of technology and other hobbies
you discover how similar they are I
would have never guessed that I would be
making off by one errors in knitting two
then the last learning is that it feels
really great to take up something that
you know nothing about so many of my
teammates said it was the most fun and
challenging thing they had done all year
learning something brand new and very
different from what you do day to day is
really humbling challenging and
refreshing and it reminds you what it's
like to be a beginner which is really
important to gain empathy with any new
programmers that you might work with or
mentor and there's a lot left to do and
explore in this whole space and the
amazing thing about giving this talk at
conferences is that at every conference
people have talked to me about
interesting ideas for how to take the
knitting machine further on the web
interface axis it would be great to make
an interface where you can draw an image
and send that to the knitting machine
without needing to use an already
existing image and maybe it could even
preview what your design would look like
with different colored yarn and another
goal I had for a while after hacking
meditating machine was to learn how to
use the machine itself better to knit
whole garments like socks sweaters
sweaters with sock sweaters socks with
toes and then when I gave this talk at
Madison Ruby a programmer named Liz I
Benante who was also a knitter told me
about a knitting machine academy in
Seattle where they teach you how to use
old living machines to make full
garments
so I sign up for a weekend intensive
there brought my computer and my table
and learned to make all the pieces of
the sweater I'm wearing right now and
the lesson there is that sharing what
you've worked on with the community and
audience just makes the project even
better on the hardware hacking axis it
would be amazing to figure out how to
automate more of the knitting process
like a robotic arm that moves back and
forth and I've also been reading about
hacks that replace the whole logic board
of the knitting machine with an Arduino
and that would be fun to try to to be
able to control more of the interface of
the knitting machine itself like showing
your project showing your progress and
how much more you have left in it and
lastly I would love to talk to you about
your ideas if you care about hardware
hacking knitting combining code with art
or creative ideas for computer science
education thank you so much for
listening and so much for having me
um and I think we probably have time for
some questions yes
um so the question was did I seem this
sweater myself or did the Machine do
that so I guess when machine knitting
there's something called a joiner it's
like an additional machine and you like
put the pieces on it and it puts them
together so it's like a separate
component and so the question was how
long did the Knitting in the video take
in real time i would say about 15
minutes but that's still like much
shorter than it would take to knit that
by hand yes
so the question was if the machine could
taken conductive thread or other
wearable technologies and it should
totally be able to and I haven't tried
and that's an amazing idea thank you yes
um I guess hackathons at Airbnb we're
really funny um maybe partly because of
this knitting machine project and like
basically every single other project ID
I had was like completely unrelated to
like web development or like our
day-to-day product but they thought that
it sounded like a fun project and that
we should go ahead and do it
and so the question was I mentioned
wanting to introduce more creative ideas
in computer science education and if
I've incorporated this knitting project
into that and I haven't and I I
definitely do so I'm currently writing a
series of ziens one of months about
different computer science topics and so
far I've covered things like logic
circuits and sorting and computer memory
and the plan for the December zine was
to interview a bunch of people who have
done interesting things with computer
science that you don't normally think of
when you think of computer science I
have friends who use computer science
for social justice applications or to
make like generative visual art and I
want like a chapter for each of those
things so that high school students will
know like wow these are the range of
things that I can do with computer sign
and that would be super amazing i would
love to do that I guess
the question was did I reach out to
Nintendo at all and did they respond I
didn't as soon as i read that they
didn't have any prototypes available I
just like went full-on into like
searching for machines that could do it
I do wonder if they would be willing to
like revisit that though and I would
totally want to to help make that happen
uh-huh
oh yeah um we're friends she's really
awesome
um so yeah this machine only did two
colors you can get a mesh like an add-on
to do up to four colors
um so the question was how expensive are
the machines and have I posted the build
steps anywhere so I think it varies the
one that I got on craigslist was five
hundred dollars and I expensed it and I
owe the other question was about whether
there's like a resource list and a
couple of knitting clubs have asked me
if like I detailed my steps anywhere so
that they can like recreate it and so
it's I've definitely sent out the list
of steps to some people and I should
probably make it public in and send that
out
thanks so much